hello there welcome to another episode
of science and technology q a for kids
and others
and
i'm happy to talk about all sorts of
science and technology topics if you
give me a topic i'll try and talk about
it um it doesn't have to be a specific
question uh
we're
covering lots of topics i'm going to
concentrate i've been doing these now
for well since the beginning of the
pandemic so that's um
almost two years now um and
we've got lots of material uh it's
available in a variety of forms we're
going to cut it up and
put it into
categories and uh make these pieces
available
uh in
different ways so if you have topics
that you'd like to hear about happy to
talk about them as i say as well as
specific questions we have a few things
left over here
uh
a lot of these are rather high level
and although i'm happy to talk about
high level things i'm
hoping to keep what i'm doing here
accessible to
a wide range of folk
um
let's see
well we had a question here saved up
from aaron
about uh making the internet traceable
and untraceable
well let's let's talk about that for a
minute
so
uh sort of some basics about how the
internet works
when you
tell your computer
to
uh
for example your web browser you say you
type in your web browser well from
alpha.com
what actually happens
what happens is
your web browser has to know how to send
the request that it makes to
wolframalpha.com or from alpha.com is a
server somewhere in that particular case
i know where the servers are we have uh
several
data centers um around around the
country actually um that uh
uh computers that will respond to
requests
to wolfman alpha.com but so how does
that actually work so you type wolfman
alpha.com in your web browser
and
your computer has to then make that
request
to one of the computers that is the
award from alpha.com server how does
that work so the first thing that
happens is this thing called dns
domain name server lookup where you have
to
resolve what is wolfman alpha.com what
is its
uh what is its internet address
and what is the route that allows you to
go from your computer through the whole
network of computers that comprise the
internet to a computer that is a
wolfram.com or from alpha.com computer
so the first thing that happens
is you make a request to a dns server
actually often the routing information
is cached
is kept temporarily on your computer or
on your local network
and that allows your computer to
immediately send that request out
without having to go look up where how
is that request supposed to get routed
but assume you had never gone to
wolfmalford.com before
then it would have to go and figure out
how does it get towards mafia.com it
looks it up through this domain name
server system um that system
is also
uh
there's a whole kind of series of of
levels of that system eventually going
to i think it's 13 root name servers
around the world that are the ultimate
sort of authorities on where the routes
to different places how how you get to
certain named domains on the internet
um
and and usually what happens is if for
example let's say
some data center goes down
and so
you want to change the how you get to
this particular service
you have to propagate new routes through
the internet you have to and that takes
i don't know 10 minutes or something to
happen as you say well actually both
from alpha.com is now
some different ip address some different
route and that has to be something that
is sort of uh
propagated back
so that when people request that address
in the in
it will give the new potential address
okay
so
let's say
your computer successfully manages to
send its requests
to a server at
whatever it is well from alpha.com for
example
what does the
server what is the computer
dwarfing alpha.com computer
what does it know about the request
that's coming in
well one thing it knows is the ip
address
of your computer originating that
request so to speak
so
so whenever a request comes in
to
for example a web server http https
server
one of the pieces of information that's
passed along with that request is what
the originating ip address was the
originating internet protocol address
was
um and so
that is something where
when when you go to a website the
website will know at the very minimum
the ip address of the computer that you
made that request from
now one of the things that people
can be interested in doing
is somehow hiding their ip address and
there are a variety of ways to do that
a pretty common one
is to use vpn virtual private network
and
to go to a place where many people will
be going to the same
kind of pooled computer
and then all the requests
that that go into that computer come out
looking as if they're coming from that
same computer so for example i don't
know there might be
a
computer in i don't know pick a place um
chicago or something um that is the end
point for for vpns
for people to connect their computer
through a virtual private network so
their computer is
is communicating just with this computer
let's say in chicago
and um then any request that they make
to a website goes through that computer
in chicago and so the request will look
as if it's coming from that computer in
chicago rather than from their own
computer and the connection that they
make between their own computer and the
computer in chicago is through this
virtual private network which is sending
uh encrypted
data
uh back and forth
um i mean that that's that's also done
for when you use a website that has an
https
address that's also using encrypted data
going from your computer to that website
but the website if the website wants to
know sort of who's looking at it
it can still detect the ip address of it
still knows the ip address of the
originating computer unless you go
through some sort of pooled computer
so then there are more elaborate schemes
um one of the more elaborate schemes is
tour i
the the onion router um most developed
one was it maybe 20 years ago 15 years
ago
it was originally developed some
people say
it was um originally developed by the
u.s military
as kind of a okay you've got some
somebody out in the field somewhere
who's trying to report all kinds of
secret information
and um you don't want it to be clear
where that information is coming from
who's sending it etc etc etc so this is
sort of a mechanism for that um and
it's it's a general way to kind of hide
uh sort of traffic that's going on on
the internet so that the way it works is
is this if i can uh i think i can
describe it um
what happens is i mentioned you know you
go from your computer to some uh sort of
pool relay computer somewhere through
vpn and then out to whatever website
you're going to visit
but you can do that in many hops you can
do something where instead of just going
to one intermediate computer you go to
through 10 intermediate computers
and they're bouncing all over the world
and in the end you go
and and and you don't even know what
computers your
your your request is going through and
at the end there is some sort of exit
node where that
the computers the the the packets the
requests that are coming look as if
they're coming just from that that final
last step in the chain of places where
requests are going
and and so there are people uh i don't
quite know who does this but um
it seems like a very um uh scary thing
to do but they're people who
who
uh provide
um nodes for the tor network and
particularly exit nodes
and so
that they any when people connect to
the tor network
they're going through i don't know how
many it is you know 10 different
computers and eventually their requests
will get to a random exit node from
which they will then go and make a
request to a website
and that's um
there are other pieces of that network
that have to do with uh
websites
sort of web-like sites that that are not
part of the standard internet
uh accessible from the standard internet
but that's a that's a separate kind of
thing the the question is if you're sort
of going through the
the um if you're using the web for
example what information do you get does
does the website you're going to visit
get about you now there's lots of other
kinds of information a website can get
uh particularly when your web browser so
so normally
you're in the most simple kind of
version of a website the website is just
what comes back to your browser is just
html so it's just a kind of a plain
description of oh there's this uh header
type there's this
font color there's this characters
there's these characters
and maybe there's this specification of
image or something like this it's very
direct kind of
sort of word processor like information
about what the page should look like
but many years ago now this language
called javascript was introduced that
web browsers understand
and so what can happen is that the page
that comes back to you isn't just
something like a page of text it also
contains essentially pieces of programs
javascript programs and your browser
unless you switch it off
can run javascript programs and those
javascript programs can themselves do
things from your computer that make
further requests uh to
uh to to the um
um
to the to the
server that is serving up information
from the web
and so in principle
these things are sandboxed in the sense
that those requests those javascript
requests
get access to only very specific
information about your computer and your
web browser and so on and that's all
they can send but there are many well
there just all kinds of different
different complicated ways that things
get stored on your computer another
whole issue is cookies
when you go and visit a website
the website can put what's called a
cookie in your web browser
and a cookie in this context is not an
edible thing except by web browsers i
suppose
it's just
a a bunch of information that says this
website put this data in your web
browser
and sometimes cookies are set to expire
so it's like this will only be uh
something that's valid for an hour but
they could be valid for 100 i think what
is the limit maybe 100 years or
something they they could be permanently
stored on your computer and permanently
valid what are those cookies they're
things like here's the login information
for this website
so you go to the website once you type
your username your password all that
kind of thing
then
the website will send back a cookie that
is stored in your web browser so that
when you next visit that website instead
of you having to type your login
information again it will just use the
information that that that website
stored in your web browser telling you
tell it that you can then send back to
the web browser and it says oh yes i
know that person i've seen them before i
know that they logged in on this website
before so
so i can tell that it's okay to let them
in
um but
often there will be many many many
cookies that are put from websites
onto onto your
into your web browser
that contain all kinds of information
about what did you do on that website oh
the person was looking at buying
shoes or something so let me put some
cookie information so that when they
next come back
we show them shoes rather than something
else
um
and also as soon as there's a cookie
that
came from logging in
then it's knowing sort of who you are
every time you go and visit that website
there's a lot of
complication about
uh kind of
sort of exchanging cookies between
websites and there's a lot of complexity
to do with delivering ads and ad
networks and what kinds of cookies are
shared between different uh
different
companies effectively
because they're going through ad
networks that correspond to a particular
domain the way a web browser works
it the cookies are separated by the
domain from which the cookie was
provided so the the cookies that i we
don't use very many cookies but the very
minimal cookies that wolfman.com for
example will put i think they're mostly
login cookies um that will will put on
into your web browser um
are different from the cookies that i
don't know uh you know apple.com will
put into your web browser and and apple
the apple.com server can't request
cookies from wolfram.com and vice versa
um but if you're using some kind of ad
network where it's where the ads are
being served from a single domain that
is the same across lots of different uh
users of that then then that story
doesn't really work anymore and there
are all kinds of other elaborate uh
cross-site scripting attacks and all
this kind of thing there's a it's sort
of remarkable that these systems that
get built which are typically built sort
of because well it was convenient for
users to have this or that feature
somebody figures out some way to exploit
those features to do something that
users probably don't want them to do
and by the way when in terms of what
information is sent by your web browser
to
uh to a website for example for example
your web browser will say what version
of the web browser it is we'll also
typically say things about screen size
um it'll say um uh
i think it has a
language encoding um
and for example the screen size is
important for the web browser for the
web server because if you're on a tiny
screen you get sent a version of the
website
the that
has uh all its data kind of stacked up
so that it will fit on a small screen
whereas if you if the specification is
well you have a wide screen then it will
send you the information in a different
format and that's that the typical
concept that something's been really
popular for probably five years or more
is so-called responsive design where a
website will change the way it looks
depending on what uh um uh what what the
you know what this sort of size and
shape of the um of the of the
window in which it's being displayed is
and sometimes that kind of information
can be
represented directly in kind of the the
code that's sent back to represent the
website in this particular css code and
the website um and but sometimes it
requires the server the the web server
sending different information to specify
what to do on a different shape of
screen
so
that's a boy this is i i actually didn't
realize how complicated this was i can i
can go to many more layers of detail
here but perhaps that's a
some indication of what um uh
what kind of thing
is um is sent from your web browser to a
computer um and a little bit on kind of
how sort of privacy preserving
uh mechanisms work
um
things like um
uh there's there's
there's a variety of different methods
for making things like
this tor network that i mentioned
there's a blockchain outfit called nkn
that um uh i've been a bit involved with
that that
i was kind of pleased that they
made use of a bunch of science that i've
done
um i wrote this big book called the new
kind of science nearly 20 years ago now
uh whose abbreviation is nks new kind of
science
and this network's abbreviation is this
blockchain's abbreviation is nkn for new
kind of network
um and its
way of working
is kind of uh something where you have
many computers
and you're sending
you're sending packets of information
between these computers
uh much as the internet sends packets of
information between computers but in
this case the way it works is there's a
cryptocurrency effectively that is being
used to essentially pay people to have
traffic go through their computers um
and uh and that that's the way that it
will be transmitted and by having enough
computers i forget how many they have
now a few hundred thousand i think
by having enough computers and the
traffic is is routed sort of randomly
between those computers
it's it's hard to tell what went where
and that's a a way to preserve kind of
the privacy of things it's also
advantageous potentially to say well if
somebody has a really fast way to route
traffic
and
you can essentially pay them to uh
through cryptocurrency to route your
pa your traffic through their computer
or through their piece of some network
and that's some a way that you can kind
of get a faster internet and so on
well let's see
um
the question here
um
that's a question from aaron can i
describe how packets get dropped
um
in okay in the internet all right so
this is a complicated story and i don't
completely know the answer to this and
i've wondered about this myself
when
so
in computer networks
when you are sending data
to from one computer to another
the data is sort of packaged up into
packets
so it's usually not always but there are
some other cases where it doesn't quite
work like this but usually instead of
just sending a long string of you know
millions of bits of data you send these
packets of data that have a certain
length i don't know 2 000 bits or
something like this
and so you'll send one packet
you wait for it to be delivered maybe
you and well you'll send packets in some
sequence
and one of the things that can happen is
depending on what route those packets
take even though you had
sent them out in order one two three
four five they may not arrive in that
order and so when they arrive the thing
that's that's receiving them has to
potentially reorder them so some
protocols
for
sending things through
uh through computer networks
actually have some mechanism to tell the
the computer that sent the packet yes
this packet arrived maybe send another
one or no this packet didn't arrive
resend that same packet so for example
the tcp
protocol which is the protocol used
underneath
http
is um
is a is a protocol that has this feature
that it has a response where it sends
back
um the information so it sends back sort
of a receipt that yes the packet arrived
you'll resend that packet and so on for
example the udp protocol which is the
one used for streaming video and things
like this does not have that feature um
so far as i know and uh
it it so that's something where if you
are sending out video it's more
important that you
send the video out and that it get
received then if if there's a little
glitch and some video gets dropped well
that's a little bad but not terrible if
you're trying to send some program or
some text file or something and
something got dropped that's much worse
and that's why tcp protocol is usually
the thing used for that
now in terms of why packets get lost
the
when you send these packets of
information
usually
you will
see well all the packets went through so
for example you can use some
uh
um
well ping is one one way to do it where
you say ping is sending one packet of
information maybe just 256 bytes perhaps
from your computer to some remote
computer and the remote computer will
sort of echo it back uses a different
protocol i think that's using uh icmp if
i remember correctly that it's a it's a
different protocol from tcp and udp it's
a specific protocol for ping
where it's like this is a test is your
computer actually connected to another
computer uh to some specific other
computer you're sending out from your
computer you send um
and the other computer is then sort of
set up to respond to that ping and send
back uh something saying yes i received
it and so one often talks about ping
time which is the time that it takes the
round trip time that it takes for the
packet to get sent to the remote
computer and then come back to you so
for example it might be you know a short
ping time might be 100 milliseconds 0.1
seconds
long ping times might be a second or
more and eventually
if the ping time is too long if it takes
too long for the packet to come back um
it will time out
and many kinds of services
that sort of try and communicate between
computers if the if those times are too
long they'll just time out and they'll
say sorry you can't connect to this
other computer uh adequately to run this
particular kind of service
but you quite often see a certain amount
of packet loss
in when you
are seeing uh
um packets
that are sent through ping through the
internet
um
and you see uh even in a local network
when you have computers connected
through wires or fiber optics locally
you'll still see some amount of packet
loss what causes packet loss well a
variety of different mechanisms but one
very obvious mechanism
for example on a local network is
uh
that
uh for example ethernet common protocol
for local network
um it
okay so you have one computer that wants
to send a packet so it just says okay
i'm going to send this packet what does
that actually mean if it's sending it on
a electrical wire or something it means
it's going to have some voltage that it
uh puts on that wire and it's going to
have it's going to sort of um
send through the signal that is based on
voltage spikes on the wire
okay so the computer says well i want to
do that right now
but another computer says well i want to
do that right now as well
most of the time
if the computers if there aren't if the
total number of packets being sent
is a a tiny fraction as it usually is of
the total amount of time so most of the
time computers are not sending packets
back and forth between each other it's
just well when you press that key to say
i want to go look at that website when
you're getting data back from that
website those kinds of things then there
is data being sent
through the network but most of the time
your computer isn't particularly sending
data through the network
so the way that ethernet for example
works
is it assumes that most of the time
there won't be there won't be very many
computers trying to communicate through
this network and so on and so what
happens is it just says okay computer
you know whenever you want to send data
just send this packet through
okay well the problem is if another
computer happened to send a packet
through at the exact same time there'd
be a collision and the whole thing would
get munged and nothing good would come
out
uh the the sort of the electrical signal
would sort of get nastily combined
together and you wouldn't get a useful
thing out
so what then happens is
i think in ethernet it has exponential
back off which means it will send a
packet
something bad happens we'll try and send
the packet again and let's say a second
and then if something bad happens again
it'll wait two seconds
something bad happens again it'll wait
four seconds it'll keep doubling the
amount of time that it waits to send
another packet through
and so but and it sort of hopes that
eventually things will clear out and
it'll be successful at sending a packet
through but it's kind of a random thing
and if the total amount of traffic on
the network gets high enough it's sort
of inevitably the case that just by
random chance a bunch of these packets
will collide with each other and so you
will get packet loss
um as a result of the packets just
munging each other through being trying
to sort of send electrical signals to
the same wire at the same time
so that's a typical example of packet
loss another example of packet loss
somewhat different cause
is for cell phones and things
where you're sending electrical you're
sending uh radio signals from a cell
phone tower to a cell phone and uh there
will be
uh you know you're transmitting that
radio and you're walking around and and
you know trees are swaying in the wind
and the radio is is the radio waves
are going but
going sort of that environment sometimes
some amount of uh radio signal will be
attenuated will be absorbed by a tree or
something like this because you happen
to happen to be a tree there or or
alternatively in a somewhat more subtle
way there are multiple channels of radio
being used by effectively different
users of the network and so things can
happen with one user's uh
sort of the the interference between
what happens from from data from one
user another more or less
um but again
in that case there can be packet loss
associated purely with the the uh the
fact that the radio signal was sent and
it wasn't received you know if it's
raining for example you can get all
kinds of packet loss
of
of of radio signals and things like this
so that's another type of packet loss i
think there are
there are forms of packet loss
that happen on the internet
that
are
mostly i suspect have to do with timing
things very similar to ethernet of
things arriving at the same time
some some um
some router
says oh i got these two packets at the
same time i i've only got one wire to
route them out over i've got to reject
one of these packets uh those kinds of
things
um i think that uh
uh
yeah people i haven't heard this for a
long time but maybe oh gosh when was it
25 years ago or more people were talking
about internet storms
which were kind of places where for
various reasons so many packets that
accumulated in that place and that uh
everything got kind of gummed up i
remember a long time ago i worked on um
on a parallel computer
that had 65 000 processors and it had
the problem of routing information
sending information from one processor
to another and one of the issues was it
had only a limited number of wires that
would connect these processors together
it was effectively it had
every processor was connected directly
to 16 other processors i think
and um there was all uh arranged in this
in the sort of giant
hypercube of uh
you know as far as the connections were
concerned hypercube of 65 000 processors
and that
uh and the question was if you wanted to
send a signal from this place to that
place
which which wires would you use and then
what would happen
if too many signals arrived at the same
place at the same time and there was a
fixed size of buffer that would be allow
you to to store
um
the uh
to store sort of packets that were
waiting to be sent out or uh data that
was waiting to be sent out and if that
overflowed um you would lose data there
that's another example of um
a kind of um
way that way that data gets lost in
networks
um i think
the uh so it's all a little bit
mysterious and you can see
in different places different situations
you'll see different amounts of packet
loss if you um
i don't know in in um
uh
i like to
walk around where i am and i i have um a
kind of a a um
a walk around outside when it isn't too
cold outside
um and
i've i've often chased kind of packet
loss of various kinds um that is
associated with literally sort of
physical distance to a transmitter or
or various kinds of vegetation in the
way and things like this it's it's very
um gets very kind of practical and when
people setting up cell phone systems for
example there's this whole question of
where do you put the cell phone towers
so that you get good coverage
independent of whether there are leaves
on the trees and whether this is
happening and that's happening
how do you make sure you get good
coverage in all places and it's it's
often tricky to figure out where should
you put these cell phone towers and you
have to get somebody to agree to let you
put a cell phone tower on a building or
in a piece of land in some particular
place and and so on and it's it's uh
it's quite a challenging essentially
engineering and mathematical problem to
figure out where do you put the cell
phone towers to get the best uh coverage
and so on
well let's see
um
there's a question here
uh from uh
raj
uh about limitations of mua's law
well so first of all i have to explain
what moore's law is
um so
it's always been
people always think computers get faster
the engineering of computers gets better
and moore's law was a kind of a
an observation from gordon moore founder
of intel
that said
let's see computer speed what is it
doubles every 18 months is that right i
think that's the right um right right uh
numerical
version
but the
this was something back from the 1960s
70s and so on
people managed to make computers go
faster and how did they do that
well
from the time microprocessors were first
developed the big issue had to do with
things like how fast could you run how
fast could you run signals through the
microprocessor and not have the signals
uh kind of
die off get attenuated not have the
signals interfere with each other and so
on
so
it's a question when you have a computer
it has
ultimately a cpu chip that has maybe
these little tiny features that are
etched on it effectively with
photolithography that correspond to
maybe these days hundreds of millions or
a billion transistors or more
and those represent the circuit that is
implementing your computer that is your
computer
and when the computer runs
there is a clock there's that you're
you're saying uh every that there's an
instruction that runs now there's an
instruction that runs the next
instruction next instruction next
instruction and that clock
these days usually sort of ticks about
two billion times a second maybe three
billion times a second
so it's a two gigahertz three gigahertz
um clock and that says every time at
every tick of the clock
you um are sort of executing a new
instruction in your computer cpu what
does it mean to execute a new
instruction well it means all sorts of
electrical signals have to go from one
part of the
part of the microprocessor chip to
another part and so on and there's a
question of sort of how fast can all of
that happen
and how what sort of frequency can you
use to to sort of send signals through
that through that microprocessor and
that in turn is affected by
uh how
how big the wires are effectively
they're not actual wires they're formed
they're they're channels
where there is essentially electrical
conductivity that's formed by etching
out pieces of of a piece of
of silicon basically um and uh those are
a very tiny kind of uh etched channel
and the question is how big is that
channel and that determines kind of how
fast the signal that uh how fast the
signal can change as it goes through
that channel
and so as
uh the the the widths of those channels
for example have gradually been uh been
decreasing um
these days i think what is the state of
the art
four nanometers maybe um
the uh that means um uh
um
four billionths of a meter so that's
about the size of um oh maybe that's
40 50 atoms across something like that
um
the um
so that's a that's the size of this
effective wire and as that gets smaller
and smaller you're able to make things
go faster and faster
well that was the story for quite a long
time that people it was very tricky to
make uh these microprocessors have these
smaller and smaller features and it
required more and more careful
manufacturing you know if you have a
piece a speck of dust anywhere there
it's like super bad news just just blows
away some you know that that
that particular cpu chip is like
hopeless can't be used if the if a speck
of dust landed in the wrong place at
some moment
then they're things like how do you
actually etch a feature that's that
small you can't even use visible light
to do that because visible light kind of
the light waves are kind of too big and
bulky to actually be able to image
something that small so you have to use
ultraviolet light or x-rays to do that
that's all complicated engineering you
have to make sure that all kinds of
things don't happen
when you have to have very very
perfect silicon crystals to start off
making your microprocessor chip out of
because if there's a defect in the
silicone crystal if all the silicon
atoms aren't lined up perfectly right
then that will make a place where the
chip won't behave the way it was
supposed to behave and so on and then
there are tricks like well if you're
making let's say a memory chip where
there are a lot of identical elements
you can say well i'm going to just make
a billion elements on this chip and i'm
gonna know that one percent of those
elements won't work because there'll be
some defect in the silicon crystal or
there'll be some other some other issue
and so then you you make that billion
element uh
uh memory chip and then you test every
element in it and you just set it up so
that it has a
sort of memory on the memory chip of
which elements of the memory chip
actually work
and it only sends data to those elements
that work it has something that is
translating addresses so that it only
sends data to the elements that work
so that's a the whole series of tricks
which which uh
have been sort of developed over the
course of of 50 years or more um making
progressively faster microprocessor
circuits
and this worked pretty well until maybe
10 15 years ago now
for a long time people were saying
eventually we're going to get to a
gigahertz we're going to have a billion
instructions per second
the [ __ ] frequency of
a a billion cycles per second and so on
and then that was achieved and then
people said we're going to go faster
than that but actually for example clock
frequencies have not increased that much
in the last 10 years of typical you know
if you go to your computer and you you
go to the sort of about this computer
tab it will tell you things like the
clock frequency of your computer and it
might be 2 gigahertz 2.5 gigahertz
something like that
um you you don't see it advancing up to
you know 10 gigahertz 50 gigahertz
things like this
and so this kind of exponential increase
of of sort of the raw speed of
microprocessors kind of slowed down and
and for example i know we we just got
new servers
for uh wolfman alpha
and uh our previous servers have been 10
years old and i was a little
disappointed that things didn't get
super much faster when we got these new
servers um they they got a bit faster
for reasons that were not specifically
to do with the servers themselves that
had to do with memory configurations and
so on i should say that among the other
so so one question is what's the sort of
raw speed of the microprocessor then you
start getting into well what you
actually care about is the speed of
programs you run on the microprocessor
and so then there are all kinds of other
engineering things you can do
to make the effective speed of programs
you run be faster so for example one
very
common one is
so-called memory hierarchy idea
so the point is that when you're doing
operations on your cpu
then you might say well i'm going to add
this number to that number okay where
did you store those numbers
did you store those numbers in a place
that was really fast for the cpu to get
those numbers from
so that it can do the addition and get
the results in
uh you know in in uh a billionth of a
second or something or does it somehow
have to fetch the data for each of those
numbers from further away
from uh
from kind of a a slower kind of storage
and so
the idea of the memory hierarchy is that
you can have things like a level one
cache a level two cache now one cache l2
cache and so on you have these different
kinds of local storage of things that
are
progressively store more but are slower
so like the level one cache will be will
be just a
i don't know how much how big they are
these days um maybe a few kilobytes of
data
that
are stored extremely much close to the
place where the operations are done in
the cpu and they're very fast memory
very easily accessible and so if the
thing that you are trying to compute
with is in that l1 cache then you can do
it really fast if it was well it wasn't
we didn't know you were going to compute
with that and it's all the way out in
the main memory of your computer that
can take many clock cycles to go fetch
that data from the main memory of your
computer bring it into the place where
it can actually be operated on by by
your cpu and so one of the things that
then happens is can you be predictive
can you figure out
uh what what
data you're going to need before you
actually need it can you do that for
example by analyzing the program that is
being run on the computer can you even
do it by for example one thing you can
do is if if there are two branches that
the code could take you could actually
uh start fetching the data for both
branches even though you don't yet know
which branch the code is actually going
to take so that's another trick and so
there's a there's just more and more and
more of these clever tricks
to do with uh sort of how you manage
sort of getting the data to the right
place at the right time so that it can
be effectively faster to operate on even
though the cpu didn't get any faster
well
the other thing that's a big issue is
you write a program in i don't know
well from language in c in java whatever
else eventually that's going to have to
get turned into the machine code of your
computer eventually your computer has a
fixed number of op codes that say things
like add two numbers together store this
piece of data in memory in this location
etc etc etc these are these are the
machine code operations of your computer
eventually everything you do has to be
translated into that machine code and
the question is given a particular
operation you want to do what's the most
efficient machine code that does that
operation you want to do so you have
some program you've written how is that
program most efficiently turned into
machine code
and again there's a was has been a lot
of development in how best to do that
even an example is well optimizing
compilers is one type of thing where
there's a question of well there are
many possible ways that you could do
this particular operation in machine
code there are many possible machine
code programs that will execute the same
operations when you look at it at a high
level let's say a level of orphan
language it's a very high level or even
the level of c code which is very close
to sort of just a more human readable
version of the kind of things that are
directly
done by a computer in them in its
machine code and so there are things
that seem at first quite crazy like you
could say
well let's just take the instructions
that um
let's just do a random search
for programs or for orderings of
instructions and programs to just see
in the in this random search most of the
randomly arranged or randomly searched
for programs won't do the right thing at
all they'll just do something completely
crazy but every so often you'll find a
program that is yes it does exactly what
i want
and you might not have figured out by
sort of thinking about it in an
engineering way well you could do this
instruction and then this one and that
will have the data ready in this place
and so on and so on and so on but by
doing even just this random search you
can often find these super clever if you
look at them clever and often kind of
incomprehensible
ways in which the computer can say yep i
can do it i can do it faster there so
that's another example of how it's been
possible to sort of tweak the speed of
things
well there are really two frontiers
of
being able to make things go faster one
is that the level of software and the
other is at the level of well i guess
that sort of they they they merge into
each other
one of the issues is if you have
a a piece of code it's written in a
language like c it's written in
the
it it just sort of specifies what a
computer can do should do
a standard computer should do
but
let's say that you know that a bigger
big thing for you to want to do in your
programs is take an array of numbers
and uh add it to another array of
numbers let's say add the corresponding
numbers and the two arrays let's say
that was an operation you you commonly
want to do or you want to do some
operation where you take two arrays of
numbers and you multiply the
corresponding numbers and add the
results up a dot product and and then
our algebra
so let's say you know you really want to
do those operations a lot
well then you can actually make special
purpose hardware that is specially set
up so it has all of its memory arranged
and it has maybe many uh parallel
units that all do addition of numbers
and they all operate in parallel across
this whole
long array this long register that
contains all these different numbers and
so on you can set that up all in the
hardware that of your kind of
microprocessor and so that's most of the
story of gpus graphics processing units
um is that what's been done is it's been
sort of noticed that there are these
particular operations particularly
operations on arrays of numbers
which are commonly things you want to do
they're things you want to do in doing
computer graphics they're things you
want to do in processing video the
things you want to do these days in some
kinds of machine learning operations
there are particular operations that are
sort of common lumps of computational
work that you want to do and so then the
idea is to make pieces of hardware that
are as efficient as possible at doing
those things now it's then challenging
if you've got well i want to just do
this run this program that i just made
up from scratch
well there's no guarantee that that
program that you made up from scratch
will will will kind of correspond nicely
to the things that are sort of efficient
to do with the gpu and so that's sort of
a
it will be as it's less easy to convert
the programs you have to gpu programs
than it is to convert the the programs
you have sort of every programming
language is set up to be able to be
converted to the ordinary machine code
of a cpu it's a more specialized thing
to convert to for example a gpu so one
thing that can happen is some operations
like playing a video or something like
that can get dramatically faster because
they're things where they are uh sort of
specifically using the things that have
been implemented in hardware in for
example a gpu whereas sort of your
general operation that was just an
arbitrary computer algorithm won't get
particularly faster because it's just
using these standard instructions and
standard op codes and so on which are
not kind of set up to be specifically
the gpu kinds of kinds of operations
so it's a little confusing when you look
at you know benchmarks of computers and
it's sort of a question well what do you
want to do with the computer um that
will determine uh sort of the effective
speed of the computer and if you look
you know like we have these wolfram mark
things for waltham language which are
sort of benchmarks on different kinds of
computers and we try to sort of spread
out the things that are done
to do that testing
across different kinds of operations
things that access memory a lot things
that do a lot of things that can be done
inside gpus things that cannot be done
in gpus and so on to sort of spread it
out to give you some rough approximation
to quotes typical usage um of uh of your
computer through wolfram language but
there's there's in a sense there's no
typical because it depends on what
you're trying to do
okay so that's on that side now the
other side it's the question of well can
you make the actual raw hardware of the
computer faster
and the basic technology of computer
microprocessors
of making uh things out of silicon and
so on that's pretty much been the same
since well really the 1960s
but gradually
sort of tweaked with more and more
clever and clever engineering solutions
to things
um there's a question of is there sort
of a fundamentally faster way to do
computation
and one of the things that actually well
science that i've done strongly suggests
is that you can do computation with
almost anything there's this thing i
call the principle of computational
equivalence
which says that
any pretty much any system whose
behavior isn't obviously simple will be
capable of doing computation as
sophisticated as as anything else
so if you just have something which is
some very simple rule you have let's say
an array of black and white dots that's
something i've studied a whole bunch um
and you just have some rule that says uh
depending on locally which black and
white dots are next to each other update
the the sequence in this way just with
rules like that you can make a universal
computer you can make something which is
computationally as sophisticated as
anything
but
present day computers are always based
on the specific idea of representing
uh kind of
data
through the presence of electrons in a
semiconductor
and having sort of operations be
represented by
gates that are made by having voltages
and semiconductors and and currents of
electrons going through semiconductors
and so on very specific piece of physics
that's used to actually set up computers
as they have existed for the last 50
years or more
now in the early days of computers
people had all kinds of experiments they
tried about can we store memory for
computers in i don't know one of the
more exotic ones which was used was uh
mercury delay lines where you would have
uh liquid mercury
uh like an old very old-fashioned
thermometer um or
and you would have a essentially a
loudspeaker that would be playing sound
through this mercury tube
and the sound is is causing compression
and
rarefaction waves in the mercury and
it'd be going through this tube and
you'd be recycling that sort of sound so
in a sense you're storing information by
the fact that there's this delay
in you know you you play sound at one
end of the mercury tube and it takes i
don't know some number of hundreds of
milliseconds or something to get to the
other end of the mercury tube and then
you go and cycle it back again and that
kind of continual recycling of in that
case sound waves was used to store
persistent information
well that particular method absolutely
went went away um and then there were
many different methods there was a core
memory was an early method where you
would have a essentially tiny magnets
and depending on whether the magnets
were magnetized in one direction or the
other direction that would store a one
or a zero bit
a bunch of different schemes
and so as we think about sort of the
future of computers we can think about
what kinds of physics could we use to
store information
and so a lot of the work that is done in
quantum computing is all about different
and often quite exotic methods of
storing bits of information and then
doing operations on those bits of
information and they're different sort
of different kinds of physics that you
can imagine using whether it involves
superconductors whether it involves
kind of microwave cavities whether it
involves different kinds of things where
the goal is always the same thing that
you need something where you're storing
you can store bits of information and a
way in which you can have those bits of
information interact now i suspect that
there are many many ways to do this and
in fact i you know i strongly believe
from the science that i've done that
there are just a huge number of ways to
do this
and that you can sort of piggyback on
almost any physical system to make
something computational the challenge is
usually preparing the particular
computation you want to do and then
reading out the results you know when
you have let's say a fluid water
that's uh uh you know all turbulent and
and
moving in very complicated ways that's
doing a computation the problem is can
you specify that you want this
particular computation of working out
the enterprime number or something being
done by that by that fluid and then if
the fluid does the computation can you
read out the answer that's more
challenging than the actual process in
many ways of doing the computation
itself
so the sort of a question of what
methodologies will be found what
technologies what systems will be found
convenient
to uh to actually
uh do the do computation with and so for
example one thing i've actually been
studying recently is doing computation
with individual molecules
and doing these operations like storing
a bit in the state of a molecule having
these operations be done by interaction
between two molecules
by essentially chemical interaction
between two molecules or at least
electrical interaction between two
molecules and so on and so that that's
really the the question and the
challenge is what what physical
processes can one use to do computation
and right now we're down to i don't know
what is these days maybe um a few tens
of thousands of electrons per bit
um
in in typical
modern
semiconductor devices and so on and so
there's a question could you get it down
to one electron per bit probably
couldn't get it lower than that because
electrons are sort of the the you know
that's sort of a those are elementary
particles um
in our current theory of physics we
think that they are things that have
structure but the structure is
unbelievably tiny compared to anything
that we are uh
that we deal with in instead of everyday
physics that we can manipulate it's
trillions and trillions trillions of
times smaller than that structure is
than the actual
size of things that we can manipulate
directly ourselves but so the question
would be can you get down
the kind of storage of information to a
single electron or a single kind of
other particle that's kind of the
minimum that we have any hope of being
able to manipulate with current physics
technologies um and uh one of the issues
then is by the time you're at that level
of smallness
all sorts of effects of quantum
mechanics and so on start being really
important and in quantum mechanics it's
kind of like well
it isn't the case that we can say the
particle definitely did this thing we
said there are many paths the particle
could have followed and we only know the
probabilities for those different parts
we because of the way that we measure
things just like we are not sensitive to
where individual gas molecules go in the
air in front of us we're only sensitive
to kind of very large scale effects if
there's an air current here or there's
an air current there not this air
current is made from a trillion trillion
actual um
uh actual molecules or something
and so similarly in quantum mechanics
and this is sort of based on our
very recent theories about how
fundamental physics works
the you're usually not sensitive to
those sort of individual threads of
possible history in quantum mechanics
it's some whole bundle of threads
because we are like pretty big observers
of kind of the quantum world so there's
sort of a question then of how small can
you get things when you have sort of a
single electron it's kind of being
buffered around and it isn't the case
that you can sort of identify the
specific thing that happened and so
there's an issue there of how do you do
computation when you sometimes can't
identify the specific thing that
happened it's again this problem of how
do you connect the computation that's
going on to what you can measure about
the computation
um
the uh
so
that's some but so this question of of
uh can you make computers faster faster
faster
part of that is what do you want to do
with the computer can you make sort of
software can you make computers whose
hardware is optimized for the particular
operations one wants to do and then can
you speed up the raw computer using a
different kind of physics probably
because probably most of the engineering
tricks over the last 50 years that could
be done with semiconductors and so on
they probably haven't all been done
there probably is another another few
that can get done but the rate of of
sort of uh
the rate of progress has definitely
slowed down in that regard and uh it's
it's and the effort
to sort of squash out another small
increase of you know 10 percent in speed
and so on it's becoming a lot of effort
it's a very well optimized thing if
there's a completely new technology
something operating with individual
molecules or some such other thing you
can fully expect that when that first
becomes available it's like well this is
cool and maybe it's fairly fast but
there'll be a long period of you know 50
years or more as things get gradually
made more efficient people realize oh if
you did this and you you know arrange
the molecule this way and you put this
extra iron atom here and you do this and
this and this you can make things go
much faster that will be a gradual
process of engineering improvement
over some fundamental idea but right now
there isn't really a a front and center
fundamental idea that's like yes this is
obviously going to be the next
generation of what computers of how
computers are built i mean i i kind of
think that
one of the models we have is is biology
and its way of using sort of molecules
to do things for us biologically so to
speak and i think that's sort of an
indication that there are ways to do
sort of molecular scale computing but we
don't really know how to do that and how
to set up programs how to read out data
and so on well from that something i'm
actually pretty interested in myself
let's see maybe um
one or two more questions here
uh
okay so there's a question from saul
here if an alien civilization sent a
spacecraft from uh proxima centauri to
earth at the speed of light
can we detect it before it arrives
i think the answer to that is no
not in the usual in our usual theories
of physics
so
in
what we believe about physics
it's only approximately true in our sort
of new theories of physics but what we
have traditionally believed in physics
is the speed of light is the absolute
upper limit on how fast we can send a
signal from here to there and that's
true for light
it goes at that speed gravitational
waves seem to go at that speed
that is the fastest things can go
and things can go at that speed when
they're massless particles photons seem
to be massless particles gravitons seem
to be massless particles other particles
neutrinos have very uh not quite
massless they have a tiny mass but they
go very close to the speed of light
the the ability to go at the speed of
light is something that is associated
with specifically particles that don't
have a rest mass
the um so that's sort of the fastest the
signal can go
so
uh the next question is okay
what kind of a spacecraft could you have
that could go at the speed of light i
think the answer is it doesn't look good
it's it's one of these things where
if you say can i could i ever go at
speed of light you know i have the most
amazing spacecraft and i want to go at
the speed of light
um i think the only way you get to go at
the speed of light is to be made of a
bunch of photons and we're not made of a
bunch of photons we're made of atoms and
it's something where you won't be able
to get you can get it'll get more and
more difficult as you as you try and get
closer and closer to the speed of light
the effective mass the effect of inertia
increases that's a consequence of
relativity um and it gets harder and
harder you have to have a stronger and
stronger rocket engine so to speak to
push you to go faster faster faster and
it gets infinitely hard as you get
towards at the speed of light and at the
speed of light the only way to sort of
be a successful thing traveling at the
speed of light is to be a photon or some
other massless particle so in terms of
can the the alien critters go at the
speed of light actually at the speed of
light the answer is no
um not unless they're made of photons
and it's kind of like uh you can imagine
i think this was the uh the backstory of
the star trek transporter that it kind
of uh just turned every person or thing
into pure information or something that
could be transmitted at the speed of
light and then it was reconstituted at
the other end it's kind of like you have
a 3d scanner that goes down to the level
of atoms at one end and it says okay
this is how you're made and then it
destroys you
and then it sends the data about you and
it then reconstructs you at the other
end and it's sort of an interesting
philosophical problem then is it the
same you at the other end when you've
been disassembled and reconstructed or
not
and that's an interesting question
because for example in our current
theories of physics as we kind of move
around physical space
we're made of different atoms of space
we we get we we are you know as i move
my hand
my hand seems to be this thing that
stays as my hand so to speak but it is
made of different atoms of space as it
moves it's kind of like if you're on a
computer screen and you've got a little
little you know creature in a computer
game or something that creature stays
seems like it stays to be the same
creature even as it moves around on the
screen but it's made of different pixels
and it's the same kind of thing when
we're talking about actual motion of
physical objects in in physical space
so i i think the um
uh that's that's its own issue but as
far as you know detecting the
approaching spacecraft
in
clearly if the spacecraft was going
below the speed of light and was
emitting kind of radio signals or
something it's like yes we might be able
to detect that
or
maybe it was a glowing you know maybe it
has some
some giant um
uh
flashing lights or something on it um
that we could detect uh which will be
coming to us at the speed of light
the interesting thing which is the thing
that einstein noticed in 1905
is
that
the
the idea is that uh to us
the light seems like it's coming at the
speed of light but even to
the aliens on the spacecraft that's
going at 99 percent of the speed light
or something
light that you emit still looks like
looks to them as if it's going at the
speed of light so it's like the the
thought experiment is you take a
flashlight
the flashlight is producing light that
goes at the speed of light you run very
very fast with a flashlight
does the light that comes out of the
flashlight in the direction that you're
running come out at faster than the
speed of light or just at the speed of
light if you say it always just comes
out at the speed of light which is what
was implied by maxwell's equations for
electromagnetism that had come out in
the late 1800s
if it just goes at the speed of light
then that implies that something funky
must have happened with your notion of
space and time and things like sort of
the the length of the flashlight and
things like this and and and how much
space you're covering uh in each moment
of time as you run and things like that
that's the only way to have it be the
case that the speed of light can
actually be constant and that that
thinking is what led to special
relativity it's kind of a very kind of
simple logical and mathematical argument
that shows that if you're going to have
a constant speed of light then it has to
be the case that the sort of physical
length of things changes when you're
going faster and the elapsing of time
changes its rate as you go faster and so
on
let's see so
uh
all right there's a
we got nice diversity of very different
kinds of questions here um
let's see maybe i'll do one more
aaron asks referring to two questions
we've addressed today if we did have a
transporter to send ourselves to another
galaxy as a signal would packet loss be
a severe danger for those intergalactic
signals
um
well you know
there isn't a lot in intergalactic space
there's maybe one atom per cubic meter
at most
and we know that light from distant
stars
certainly does reach us here on earth
so things do get through the
intergalactic medium just fine and a
photon that is going through
a pure vacuum
will
just keep going it's just a photon it
just keeps happily chugging along
if it if it hits a hydrogen atom for
example well then it can get scattered
in a different direction and it won't
arrive in the right place or it might
get absorbed by the hydrogen atom
and emitted in a different way and so on
um
but if nothing like that happens the
photons just going to keep going that's
by the way a somewhat non-trivial fact
when you deal with kind of our current
model for what space is
in our current model for what space is
it's this giant network of kind of atoms
of space
at a very tiny scale where the distance
effective distance between atoms of
space
might be a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillionth
of a meter across
um
and so very tiny distance
but it's still the case that space
is kind of made from this kind of giant
network of these atoms of space and the
fact that we believe that there's sort
of a continuous version of space where
things can just move through it and
where you can sort of smoothly go from
one place to another
that uh that fact relies on kind of this
continual uh continual changes continual
kind of um uh updating of this of this
underlying network in space so it's not
actually totally obvious from that point
of view
that a photon that is just going in a
certain direction can just keep going
and not get scattered in any way in fact
one of the things we suspect is that in
the very early universe there were
probably fluctuations in the effective
dimension of space-time so that space
wasn't precisely three-dimensional it
might have been 3.01 dimensional or 2.99
dimensional or something and that will
affect the the propagation of photons
through through that kind of space
so i think um
uh there's sort of a question
uh the main question is if you if you
shine a very bright laser
and uh you try and get all those photons
in the laser beam to go out towards some
distance galaxy will they all actually
get to the distant galaxy well the
problem is you can't get the photons to
all be lined up in direction enough
to just be all be going in that
direction there'll be a certain degree
of of sort of spreading out i think i
don't know how big they are but i think
when people shine uh intense lasers at
the moon
um the uh
they try and keep the laser light as as
concentrated as possible but you still
end up with a spot that's like a couple
of kilometers across by the time it gets
to the distance of the moon so that's
going to be even broader when you get to
the to a distant galaxy for example and
that means that the number of photons
that are going to be received will be
quite small and that you know
unless you have some giant sort of thing
that is collecting all those photons and
kind of reassembling the signal that got
sent then then you will be able to
collect all the information that was
sent and i think this is one of the
features of the telecommunications world
the people that that uh even more so
than computers people have gotten the
ability to send signals faster and
faster more and more data um uh well the
signal itself
will travel at the speed of light but
the amount of data that can be packed
into a single a single packet for
example gets larger and larger um as
more and more tricks get found for doing
that and so one can imagine in the you
know advanced alien civilization that is
uh um collecting the sort of full amount
of all the photons that arrived from
this laser uh originating on earth it's
like okay we know what all those bits
were let's reconstruct uh let's see erin
it was there
when
when the bits arrive in the andromeda
galaxy or something um but the
alternative is unfortunately you know
not all the photons from the errand data
arrived and so
that means that the the reconstruction
can't be complete
one can always have a certain amount of
redundancy that is you can send two
photons to represent each bit and you
hope that at least one of them arrives
and there are much more optimized ways
to do that where you have kind of this
whole error correcting code where you've
arranged a particular pattern of bits of
data and you've arranged to have sort of
extra bits of data and you've arranged
so that the extra bits of data maximally
check or optimally check the earlier
pieces of data and optimally make
corrections if there were if there were
errors in the earlier earlier data but
yeah i think that the um the main thing
is not so much the direct kind of packet
loss that's just the spreading out of a
signal that will cause they're just only
to be you know to be zero photons not
not even one photon representing uh some
particular bits of information and you
just can't tell anything from from zero
photons
all right well i think we should wrap up
there so um
thanks very much thanks for its
questions please i i think there's a a
way to send in
uh questions or topics
that you'd like me to try to cover
um
and uh
then we can be we can be ready for
another time here and i would say that
um we'd also like feedback i'd like
feedback
on uh what things you guys find more
interesting to hear about whether the
explanations i'm giving are ones you can
understand because that's kind of the
idea that's the thing i find interesting
is is
being able to explain things that i
think i understand in a way where i
think other people can should be able to
understand them too
um so i'm interested to hear about
whether that's been working or not
um and any other suggestions because
we're we're approaching the two-year
mark
for these q a's and um i'd like to know
how do we best optimize them
all right well we should wrap up for now
and uh
um
uh thanks and